it is a staggering amount of time that
they're going to need to catch up with
this backlog
there's no doubt that covert 19 has had
an impact on a variety of services but
there is no blame here being placed on
the nhs because everyone knows what an
extraordinary year they've had
they've been very good at catching up
with urgent care procedures but it's
others that are lagging behind if we
take you through some of them that the
nhs providers have
picked up on the first one is cancer
care not necessarily referrals
but those waiting to start treatment the
other one is elective surgery
hip and knee replacements spinal surgery
nose procedures too
there are also concerns about other
areas less visible backlogs in
mental health and community services now
nhs providers have heard from a number
of trusts about this that say
it's going to take them about three to
five years to
catch up with those services we reported
on friday if you remember
that some 4.7 million people in
england as of the end of february are
waiting for their hospital treatments to
start i spoke to one of them on friday
that she was one of
387 000 people who had been waiting over
a year for a routine procedure
uh here is nhs providers chief executive
chris hopson talking
to us this morning particularly in the
early 2000s we had a similar problem and
the way we tackled it then
was effectively we did lots of overtime
we used the private sector
we had a kind of ruthless focus on
cutting waiting lists and the reality
i'm afraid is that
a we've got many more priorities now we
absolutely have to deliver the long-term
plan nhs long-term plan
we've got to work out how we uh live
long-term with covid so we haven't just
got a small number of priorities
we've got a much larger number of
priorities and the real issue is that
actually
um we're going to have to do things
differently if we just try and do it the
same way we did it back in the early
2000s we're not going to get through
this quick enough
there's a number of solutions the
organization have told us about the
first one resolves around
revolves around capacity building up the
nhs workforce
to expand how many people are in the nhs
itself we know they are overstretched as
it is the other one is restructuring
hospitals so they better
prepared to deal with further covert
waves and annual winter struggles
particularly because we know winter is a
very difficult time for them the other
one
is improving efficiency with trusts
working
better together now nhs england have had
to cope with over
400 000 covered 19 patients throughout
the past year
as i mentioned at the top they have had
an extraordinarily traumatic year but
the department of health has commented
on this today
they have told us we are backing our nhs
they say with an extra
7 billion pounds for health and care
services this year bringing our total
additional covert 19 investment to 92
billion pounds this includes they say 1
billion pounds to support nhs recovery
by tackling waiting lists and providing
up to 1 million extra checks
scans and additional operations
recognizing there the significant
challenge they have ahead
but it looks as though the government is
putting in the funding they need